sprechen wir über die neueste verrückte
aber tatsächlich man mag es kaum glauben
ernst gemeinte Forderungen von
selbsternannten Umweltschützern ein
Sexverbot für Männer die Fleisch essen
ja die schlichte Rechnung die dahinter
steckt die kommt von der
Tierschutzorganisation patter die sonst
für nacktaktionen vor allen Dingen
berühmt ist sie sagen Männer sind
schlecht fürs Klima zumindest dann wenn
sie Fleisch essen also sollen sie sich
jetzt nicht mehr fortpflanzen denn
Kinder die sagen ja dann erst recht
schlecht fürs Klima
wenn man hierauf nicht verzichten möchte
soll er hiervon nichts mehr bekommen
Sexverbot für Fleischesser was soll das
denn Daniel Cox von Peter sagt Männer
seien viel schlechter für die Umwelt als
Frauen weil sie zu viel Fleisch essen
Peter fordere deshalb ein Sexverbot für
Fleischesser hintergrund ist eine 2021
erschienene Studie wonach Männer
besonders durch ihren Fleischkonsum 41%
mehr zum Klimawandel beitragen sollen
als Frauen deshalb sollten Frauen jetzt
in den Sex Streit gehen damit ihre
Männer auf Fleisch verzichten und das
geht ja wohl mal wirklich zu weit peter
will uns also tatsächlich Fleisch essen
oder eben Sex verbieten Verständnis in
der Männerwelt für solche absurden
Forderungen Fehlanzeige egal ob Metzger
Herr klusmeyer ja für mich ist ein
absoluter Witz und nicht nachvollziehbar
und Befehle einfach die Worte oder
Menschen auf der Straße als ich esse
gerne Fleisch wenn man drei vier Tage
nur Fisch ist das steht einem bis zum
Hals und da fehlt ist vielleicht
zwischen 10 Uhr
deshalb also finde ich Schwachsinn also
ich glaube nicht dass Petra das
irgendwas angeht und das ist der erste
Punkt und der zweite Punkt ist natürlich
auch ganz einfach dass es jedem selber
überlassen ob er teures oder günstiges
Fleisch kauft die Preise sind eh überall
enorm gestiegen alle finden diese
Forderungen einfach unsinnig und das ist
nicht das erste Mal dass Peter mit
seinen Forderungen für Kopfschütteln
sorgt immer wieder fordern sie auch wer
Kinder kriegt soll auf Fleisch
verzichten weil jeder neue Mensch unsere
Umwelt belaste puh am Ende zeigen all
diese Forderung von vor allem eins sie
wollen uns mit allen Mitteln das Fleisch
essen verbieten aber Sexverbot für
unsere Männer damit gehen Sie einfach zu
weit
eine unglaubliche Kampagne von der man
wirklich erstmal glaubt das kann doch
nicht so gemeint sein das kann doch
nicht deren Ernst sein ist es das wir
fragen jetzt nach bei Daniel coxy ist
Teamleiter im kampagnenteam von Peter
und uns jetzt auch zugeschaltet
schönen guten Tag Ihnen Herr Cox und
daher auch wirklich als allererstes mal
die Frage erklären Sie uns dass das ist
also wirklich ihr ernst
ja guten Morgen erstmal das ist bewusst
ein wenig überspitzt gewählt von uns die
Botschaft wir wollen natürlich darauf
aufmerksam machen dass der
Ernährungsstil den wir als Menschheit
pflegen nicht nur unendliches Leid bei
den Tieren auslöst den für unseren
kurzfristigen Genuss grausam die Kehle
aufgeschlitzt wird und das bei
mangelhafter Betäubung nein unsere
Ernährungsgewohnheiten befeuern auch
massiv die Klimakatastrophe und dafür
wollen wir ein Bewusstsein schaffen wann
sagen sie ihr letztes Steak gegessen
Herr Cox
das ist über zehn Jahre her
das heißt in ihrem Sinne sie würden sich
selber noch Sex erlauben
das würde ich tun ja niemand von uns
wird ja als Veganer oder Veganerin
geboren sondern durch unsere Kultur
werden hier viele Menschen zunächst mal
an Fleisch oder Milchprodukte
herangeführt und es ist ja eine bewusste
Entscheidung das abzulegen glauben sie
dass sie damit mit dem Sexverbot dass
sie fordern natürlich wir reden ja auch
heute an dem Tag drüber man schafft
natürlich Aufmerksamkeit aber glauben
Sie wirklich dass man damit die
Fleischesser die Männer die wir hier in
unseren Bildern sehen die gerne am Grill
stehen glauben Sie wirklich dass man die
so auf ihre Seite rüber kriegt indem man
sagt jetzt dürft ihr nicht mal mehr Sex
haben und Würstel gibt's schon gar nicht
wir wollen Denkanstöße liefern also wir
hoffen ja dass die Menschen durch diese
Forderung jetzt ihre Ernährung
überdenken und vielleicht erstmal
vegetarisch werden im besten Fall vegan
werden und so der tägliche Mord an
wehrlosen fühlenden Lebewesen
aufgehalten wird und natürlich die
Klimakatastrophe abgewendet wird denn
auf einem toten Planeten kann sowieso
keiner mehr grillen
jetzt spielen wir das noch einmal durch
also angenommen die Frauen würden
tatsächlich flächendeckend mitmachen 96
Prozent der deutschen Männer habe ich
heute früh noch mal nachgelesen Essen
Fleisch für die wäre es jetzt aus 96%
kein Sex mehr in Deutschland
ja sie haben es ja selber in der Hand
also wenn sie sagen sie möchten weiter
Sex haben aber sich fortpflanzen können
dann können sie ja eher
Ernährungsgewohnheiten anpassen
automatisch ihren CO2-Fußabdruck
reduzieren und dann steht im Sex ja
nichts mehr im Wege also ich höre raus
ich glaube herauszuhören so richtig
ernst meinen sie das zum Glück nicht es
soll vor allem aufrütteln und noch mal
zum Nachdenken bewegen eine Sache die
mich aber dieser Kampagne stört ist dann
doch das Bild über Kinder denn Kinder
sind auch unsere Klimaschützer von
morgen ist die nächste Generation und es
soll ja verhindert werden nicht dass die
Männer Spaß beim Sex haben sondern dass
sie sich fortpflanzen das also weitere
Kinder entstehen warum führen Sie die
Kinder ins Feld ist Peter eigentlich
kinderfeindlich
wir wollen ja in erster Linie an die
grillenden Fleisch essenden Männer ran
den die zerstören letzten Endes die
Lebensgrundlagen ihre eigenen Kinder
oder sogar ihre noch ungeborenen Kinder
und nehmen billigend in Kauf Leid und
Tod von 2 Millionen Tieren pro Tag
alleine in Deutschland der
durchschnittliche Deutsche ist in seinem
Leben 1.500 Tiere und ich glaube das ist
hier die eigentliche Katastrophe also
sind sie eigentlich fein damit das
weiter Kinder geboren werden in
Deutschland dass wir hier Kinder haben
und es auch Ihr Anliegen die zu schützen
und nicht sie zu verhindern
ja natürlich allerdings muss die Politik
auch Rahmenbedingungen schaffen
Rahmenbedingungen verändern dass wir als
Menschheit eine Ernährungswert wenn die
hinbekommen zum Beispiel durch eine
sofortige Reduktion der Tierbestände
durch ausstiegsprogramme für die
LandwirtInnen oder das Abschaffen einer
Mehrwertsteuer der Mehrwertsteuer auf
pflanzliche Produkte auf Obst und Gemüse
oder eine höhere Mehrwertsteuer auf
tierische Produkte wie Fleisch nicht
Produkte Eier und Fisch dann können
natürlich weiter Kinder geboren werden
weil wir so unser Lebensgrundlagen
erhalten können indem wir eben den
Ernährungsstil ändern Herr Cox mit ihrer
Forderung also heute Seite 1 bei Bild
ist das für sie ein riesen Erfolg oder
machen sich damit als Organisation
endgültig lächerlich
es ist ein Erfolg für die Tiere weil die
Botschaft dass wir mit Tieren nicht
weiter so umgehen können wie wir das in
den letzten Jahrzehnten und
Jahrhunderten getan haben diese
Botschaft kommt jetzt an sie hören uns
zu
letzte Frage noch und die ist ein
bisschen provozierend sind ihnen Tiere
wichtiger als Menschen
alle Lebewesen sind also wichtig weil
sie alle gleich alle Lebewesen sind
fühlende Lebewesen sie können
Schmerzempfinden dass sie können Trauer
empfinden sie können Freude empfinden
und deswegen können wir Tiere nicht so
behandeln nicht anders behandeln als wir
Menschen behandeln
das ist die Meinung von Daniel Cox von
Peter der heute fordert ja ein Sex
streiken Sexverbot für alle
fleischessene Männer danke Ihnen
[Musik]